DOES NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EXONERATE ANYBODY, IT'S NOT HIS
JOB.
>> THE LEFT-WING MEDIA TODAY,
AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE THEY ARE
WERE ALL READING FROM THE SAME
SCRIPT.
>> IT'S BASICALLY NOW UP TO YOU.
HE WAS VIRTUALLY ANNOUNCING
CONGRESS, DO YOUR JOB.
>> THE TRAIN WHISTLE IS BLOWING
AND POLICY HAS TO MAKE A
DECISION.
>> IS SAYING TO CONGRESS, I
CAN'T DO YOUR JOB FOR YOU.
>> THE BALL IS IN YOUR COURT.
>> THE BALL IS ESSENTIALLY IN
THEIR COURT.
>> IT'S UP TO YOU AND A HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES TO DEAL WITH
THIS.
THE BALL IS IN YOUR COURT.
>> Laura: BRADDOCK, ARE YOU
WORRIED AFTER TONIGHT?
>> THE PERSON WHO HAD A BAD DAY
TODAY WAS NANCY PELOSI.
THEY EXPECTED -- I THINK THEY
WERE SALIVATING SOMETHING WAS
GOING TO COME.
>> HE SAID WE COULDN'T CHARGE.
HE COULDN'T CHARGE BECAUSE OF
THE DOJ POLICY.
HE DIDN'T SEEM LIKE THAT WAS HIS
JUSTIFICATION BUT I THINK THAT'S
A WASH.
I DO THINK IT WAS MUDDYING THE
WATERS ONCE AGAIN ON THIS ISSUE
OF OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
>> I STILL THINK THIS GOES BACK
TO DEMOCRATIC TALKING POINTS.
THEIR IMPEACHMENT TO THEIR BASE
IS LIKE THE WALL IS TO OUR BASE.
THE TRUTH IS, THIS IS A MADE UP
FALSE PROBLEM AND CRISIS BUT OUR
WALL IS A REAL CRISIS.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT THEM RAISING
MONEY, AND THIS WILL BE THEY
HAVE TO DANGLE THAT LITTLE
PROSPECT OF IMPEACHMENT OUT,
REALLY.
I'M THINKING AS A DEMOCRAT.
YOU KIND OF HAVE PEOPLE THINKIN
THINKING, AND THEY TALK TO HER
ABOUT BEING DISAPPOINTED WITH
THE DOJ.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I AM GREATLY DISAPPOINTED IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THAT WAS THE MISREPRESENTATION
OF THE MUELLER REPORT TO BEGIN
WITH, THEY ARE HIDING BEHIND
SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD NEVER
FIND IN THE CONSTITUTION.
>> I'M GOING TO SIT HERE BEATING
THIS DRUM.
IT ACTUALLY STRENGTHENS THE
CAMPAIGN.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY AGREE WITH.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BEAT THEM IN
SOME WAY BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
OTHER WAY TO BEAT THEM ON POLIC
POLICY.
I WANT YOU TO WATCH THIS
EXCHANGE.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO OUR
JOB AS A CONGRESS, THAT WE NOT
ALLOW MISCONDUCT TO GO
UNDETERRED.
THEY CAN VIOLATE THE PUBLIC PLUS
AND THERE ARE NO CONSEQUENCES